you mentioned that you left to go to
these posts back home a little while
yeah so what elements have allowed you
to endure living in LA the 13 years a
lot of people we know they can either it
seems like it's either or they can
either endure your own very long time or
they find out that it's it's pretty
tough and they go back home mm-hmm what
elements have allows you to do that who
it's been tough because hmm my family is
a very tight-knit close Italian family
big family and my bestest girl friends
in the world are girls that I've been
friends with since I was 12 and they all
they're all on these ghosts so it hasn't
been family and friends you know it
hasn't been and I don't want to say that
they haven't supported it because they
do and they love me and so their love
keeps me going but if any of them had
their say in the matter I would have
packed up years ago you know so there's
always that like when you come from a
close family well I guess you know in my
situation where I know in their heart of
hearts they want me to be happy but they
would much rather me be happy you know
an hour away from them than three days
um I god what has kept me going good I
don't know oh you know it's oh gosh it's
like every so often there's something
that happens and I'm trying to think of
something that happened recently that
would be one of those moments and I
can't quite think of one that would be a
great example of it um I can think of a
semi example but um there's things that
happen out here that wouldn't happen
anywhere else and you have that those
moments here's okay here's a funny one
here's a funny one sort of yoga class
last night nomex yoga class it was the
summer solstice and russell brand is in
class and Russell does recently met the
Dalai Lama and he was invited actually
introduced the Dalai Lama on stage to a
group of youth in England because of
Allah riots that happened last year
they're very concerned about the youth
of England and the Dalai Lama went to
speak and they wanted a cool hip awesome
host that the kids would get Russell
Brand so he's in yoga class last night
and our teacher called him up on the
friends in front of the class to talk a
little bit about his experience with the
Dalai Lama and you know and after class
I went over I gave Russell big hug and
we chatted for a minute and I you know
thanked him for sharing his story and
then you walk out you're like yeah that
when it happened anywhere but LA you
know like there's like little moments of
sparks um you know the cupcake pinup
photo should i mentioned that all of us
girls just did I got to like get dressed
up and be a pinup model and you know I'm
on my way home but I kept on my hair
makeup on and it's just like there's
moments like that that you're like yeah
I don't have any work this week but hey
i just got to be a pinup model or here's
a good one comic con coming up um and
something we haven't touched on I am I
just got invited to speak on my very
first panel at san diego comic-con and
um i was joking with a girlfriend of
mine the other day of like you know let
her home kind of thing like to your mom
and dad yes I don't have a regular job
and I don't have a lot of income coming
in and I don't know what I'm doing but
I'll speaking out of hand like come on
that's really like it's funny um for
yeah is it very exciting it's um Catrina
hell action chick flick calm I'm
actually she's writing over Keith nation
com now formed it but she's going to be
on the panel with us and Bonnie / and
from special-effects magazine formerly
of Lucas Films that'd go over there
she's our moderator and it's called the
dangerous women of comic-con which is
like an awesome title but I'm guessing
that's all cat that Katrina came up with
that and so basically they're just
showcasing I think they're six or seven
of us some girls I know some girls that
don't know some girls I've heard of some
girls I haven't who are what Katrina
considers the movers and shakers in this
industry right now and you know who you
should watch out for I'm debating on
whether or not I should bring my fangs
with me but I'll I don't know
you